Android phone makers are really bad about keeping your phone up-to-date...
...with the latest version of Android from Google.
There are a lot of reasons for this.
When Google makes a new version of Android,...
...it sends it off to phone makers who modify it for their own devices.
Then that has to go through a bunch of testing...
...before they send it off to carriers for even more testing.
By the time the software update finally hits your phone,...
...months have gone by and Google usually has a new version of Android by then.
The result:...
...94 percent of smartphones out there are running an outdated version of Android.
Android can also be a security nightmare...
...because there are so many different versions of Android out there...
...and phone makers have a hard time getting them updated in a timely manner.
If and when a vulnerability is found,...
...it can take forever for you to get the patch to update it.
The best example is Stagefright,...
...which was a severe vulnerability found a few years ago...
...in practically all Android devices.
Major manufacturers rushed to put out patches...
...to fix the bug but we still don't know if all of them got the patch.